فيتنام بلد يبلغ عدد سكانه 97 مليون نسمة
وأقل من 300 حالة مؤكدة من
19 حالة سرية ولا يوجد وفيات هذا هو
الرقم الرسمي من الحكومة
والذي لفت انتباه الخبراء
ووسائل الإعلام الدولية.
الفيروس لقدرة الدولة الشيوعية
على حث الجمهور على التعاون
بما في ذلك الحجر الصحي الجماعي ×
الإغلاق الإلزامي للتباعد الاجتماعي
وتتبع الاتصال العدواني
واختبار استراتيجية فيتنام في الحرب
ضد السرية 19 كانت بعيدة والوقاية المبكرة
حتى قبل أن يصبح الوباء
معقدًا.  تم الكشف عن حالتين من حالات الإصابة
بالفيروس في يناير ،
وعلقت السلطات على الفور
الرحلات الجوية إلى ووهان ، ثم أوقفت نقطة الصفر
للوباء وأغلقت الحدود مع
الصين أمام جميع التجارة الحسية
والسفر ، بالإضافة إلى
بدء تتبع الاتصال العدواني بالاعتماد على
شبكات الحزب الشيوعي الشعبية في
الأحياء.  وضع أحد سكان هانوي
الأمر نذهب  س كل زقاق
يطرق على كل باب
نتبع إرشادات حكومتنا
بأن مكافحة الوباء تشبه
محاربة عدونا ،
وجاء تخفيف القيود بعد عدم
الإبلاغ عن حالة جديدة مؤكدة في غضون أسبوع تقريبًا
ولكن السلطات هنا تصر على أن الأزمة
هي  لم ينته في الواقع ، تم إغلاق بلدة في
مقاطعة هاجونج بالقرب من الحدود الصينية
في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر بعد اكتشاف حالة إصابة واحدة بالفيروس ،
كما ظلت القيود مفروضة على
قريتين بالقرب من العاصمة
هانوي وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية.
القيود ولكن
هذا الرجل يذكر الناس بعدم
التخلي عن حذرهم ،
شكرًا لك على أنه تم تخفيف التباعد الاجتماعي
ولكن هذا التفشي لا يمكن التنبؤ به ،
لذلك لا يمكننا توقع أي شيء
في هذه الأثناء ، يسعد الكثيرون هنا
أن مظهرًا من الحياة الطبيعية قد عاد ، وقد
رأى مايكل هولمز ذلك